what is happening there reject nation
greg here
john here aaron here it's aaron's
birthday today
wish him a happy birthday comments hit
that like button for
so we're going to watch the trailer
today for the most powerful martial
artist in the marvel cinematic universe
shane she and the legend of the 10 rings
quick story
met up at 5 30 in the morning because we
thought this was coming at 6 00 am
and then see mooloo who plays chongqi
put out a
twitter post of of the poster saying
trailer won't be out for a few weeks
did a whole video breaking down the
entertainment weekly article
that came out shot for about 35 minutes
and then in that timeframe of us
shooting that the trailer actually did
come out
and now it is 6 15 in the morning and we
are running late to the trailer
let's do this
yes like bruce lee's one-inch punch
cool oh no
reliving his painful origin in my shadow
oh let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh yes
oh my goodness oh my god
[Applause]
dude
[Music]
dude that was great yes that was great
oh man
this will be the best fight in um
oh my god
that was a fantastic trailer let's watch
it one more time let's watch it again
okay
i love this you're getting like his dark
hint in his dark history but then in his
modern day personality was covering all
up he's got all that charisma and charm
is teasing the article uses humor as a
defense mechanism
yeah and
i gave you 10 years to live your life
ten years to live your life
you can tell this actor just oozes
charisma
grounded the yeah looks yeah that's so
cool
and it does feel like a like a hyper
stylized 70s kung fu film okay zack
snyder
in slo-mo it looks like it's mixing that
70s
i love that mask what is that who is
that character
[Music]
i love this classic mandarin updated
mandarin look
classic updated man yeah
some of the purple and this this this
one looks like from skyfall
yeah i see that but he definitely got
crossing tiger hidden dragon right there
a lot more of those fantasy hong kong
films
ooh omega red you supposed to be in this
age
that's a great shot it's such a great
shot
oh man the action of this
this movie is going to be so great and a
lot of the but that whole bus scene that
leaked online and
like because they were filming all
through san francisco so a lot of that
is practical
oh a lot of that thrashing of the
vehicles yeah
a lot of bmws being destroyed
yeah man i gotta get that out of
sponsorship uh paid off
smash the competition
dude it's gonna be awesome this is gonna
be great yeah
asian representation hell
yeah all right uh let's keep we talked
for so long in the other video that i'm
probably not going to put up now
so aaron what is your birthday did you
get first dibs on the thoughts what did
you think of trevor oh
man i thought it was fantastic i love
the
the tone they have going on the mandarin
new they made it
seem like it was framed like he gave
chongqi the chance to believe the world
for ten days or ten years and
now it's time to come back and it's
about like facing your legacy and like
in your complicated history with your
your past and your father and stuff and
you can just tell this actor just oozes
so much charisma and
just you can tell that he's gonna be a
true staple of the marvel universe and i
love
i love the fact that it's set in san
francisco i mean we can ant-man cameo
yeah
that'll be fantastic uh yeah i
love the action as well like like you
said in the when we were watching it
kind of remind you of skyfall some
some things reminded me of like
crouching tiger hidden dragon i love
aquafina you know she's just on a roll
like the past couple years between like
ryan the last dragon and jumanji
and now she's officially entered the
marvel universe this is just this just
seems like a great time and i'm really
hyped to see
how chiang chi not only fits into the
marvel universe but what his character
like what his journey is over the course
of these
this two hour two hour plus movie yeah
man and i think
through aquafin i'm wondering like which
perspective we're going to be honing in
on because obviously most of the
perception will be from
chongqi but it feels like there will be
an element up here where you're kind of
in aquafina shoes experiencing the
revelation
of who shang shi really is you know like
does he go by shanghi when he's in san
francisco is it a different name
so yeah john you take it away i mean
this dazzled me
this is sort of everything i keep hoping
marvel will continue to do in bringing
in more film styles and bringing in more
cultures and whatnot so
yeah i love the idea of meeting shangti
in present day
you know in a more relatable scenario
and then learning
the mantle that has been bestowed upon
him that he's trying to get away from
and whatnot you know the connections to
the sinister mandarin figure like yeah
this gave me everything i was hoping for
and
a tangibility that i always appreciate
from these movies that sells them that
much more where you can
feel the authenticity of the stunts and
the actual performers doing the action
and whatnot i can't wait for this this
is
probably the marvel i'm looking most
forward to in in current
uh time and this climate that we're
living in yeah i mean i think what's
really cool about when you're cutting to
the
the past as well is a lot of it could
have just felt like
you know pulpy kung fu flashbacks and i
love how they keep
a lot of sort of the the color aesthetic
of some of the costume design
and some of the cinematography who by
the way bill pope is doing the
cinematography for this
who did the matrix trilogy and samuraimy
spider-man 2.
so that's why it looks so damn good when
you're looking at this there's a lot of
different aesthetics here like there's
some stuff that feels straight out of
classic fantasy hong kong films as well
and then a little bit more of those
grounded takes on top of that
and the tournament looks like a lot of
fun the soundtrack was really cool and
yeah simia lou looks awesome but tony
long is mandarin or wen wu
looks great and i love how the villain
of this movie so much of marvel
characters have dealt
with father issues you know and
right down to even like guardians of the
galaxy too the villain of that being
star-lord's father
uh but you know we've seen a lot of
parental issues with the marvel
characters before but here they're doing
this
this combination of you know with the
full manchu from the comics and the
manor
and slicing them together here to tell
this real powerful personal tale so
while you got this larger than life kung
fu fantasy
fantasy film you're also getting this
real personal
villain and hero tale of choosing your
own
path you know making your own destiny
along the way and you don't you know you
see the 10 rings kind of in power
obscured at some points but i'm excited
to see because each ring has a specific
power set so i'm excited to see all they
do with that but he does look like a
very imposing villain
and i imagine they're going to have some
great chemistry on screen uh
tony chiway long end and similar this
looks awesome this looks freaking this
looks freaking fantastic i'm very much
excited for it anyway guys
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click the notification bell hit that
like button thank you so much for being
here
happy birthday erin thank you greg last
but not least
niraj krishnan you're one of my names
we're shouting you out today and listen
man i just want to give you
a brief piece of advice stop running
from the past
go back home and confront your father
all right i know he beat those martial
arts skills into you well now it's time
to use them narage you gotta leave new
york
stop letting america corrupt your mind
you gotta go and win back those ten
rings bring em back
here so that we can enjoy some of that
sweet sweet power
with you all right power is best when it
is shared
and you are a generous cat so niraj
i love you i hope you're doing well and
bring some of that power this way so
that we can know what it's like to be
special too
well taste it
you